impossible de se rendre au concert
actuellement alors pourquoi pas les
faire venir à nous à chaque année à la
même période la barbacane à ben proposer
des rendez vous gratuit à l'heure de
l'apéro et en 2020 ce sera toujours le
cas mais ce sera en ligne bonjour justin
est cette année la barbacane s'est
adapté c'est sale c'est adapté doute
l'événement est bien maintenu mais ce
sera une édition différente puisque la
tournée générale de la barbacane se fera
à la maison
alors concrètement comment ça va se
passer bien leur à trois apéros concerts
ce sera sur facebook en live à 19 heures
les 20 21 et 22 novembre
alors pourquoi des apéros visio et bien
tout simplement la directrice de
l'établissement ne l'expliquent non
c'est plutôt basé sur ce qu'on a tous
expérimenté chez nous sur la période du
1er confinement à savoir la notion d'
apéros visio donc on est parti de cet
endroit un peu ludique où on s'était dit
que c'était sympathique de proposer à
nos spectateurs qui se retrouvaient de
nouveau confiné de pouvoir à l'heure de
l'apéritif avoir un moment culturel
comment va se dérouler cette édition
confirmation eh bien les concerts vont
être transmis depuis la scène de la
barbacane parmi les arthrites les
artistes on retrouve ise sauvage donc
c'est une compositeur auteur et
interprète qui trouve son inspiration
dans la pop et la fox sera le samedi
soir et elle nous parle de son futur
apéro concert je serai accompagné avec
mon musicien bassiste qui sera là et on
jouera tous les deux à 1,7 à c'est assez
caustique j'ai eu envie de faire quelque
chose d'assez intimiste je trouvais que
c'était plus ou moins approprié de faire
ça donc oui ça ce sera une formule très
acoustique je revisite pas mal de titres
un peu anciens deux reprises une reprise
que j'aime beaucoup des valves et hommes
de blain un mot sur le reste de la
programmation
oui donc on commencera à le vendredi
avec un concert de tout quand ou quand
un groupe électro pop
le samedi soir ce sera donc ise sauvage
et puis le dimanche ce sera le chanteur
rennie dot qui nous fera voyager dans un
univers parisien à travers un jazz
manouche
sur un mois la voilà béton et du macadam
sous les pavés ouais c'est ça
[Musique]
je n'étais
qui sait
[Musique]
son
voilà ce qui vous attend ce week-end et
bien sûr si vous loupez lé concert et le
seront disponibles sur la chaîne youtube
de la barbacane vous avez déjà fait
votre choix
bien sûr moi j'allais voir les sauvages
encore plus la barbacane propose même
des kits apéro aussi qu'on peut réserver
et via pouvoir profiter merci justin